good afternoon everybody I think we'll
get started we might have one or two
people drift in but we have a lot to
talk about today so let's get our talk
underway my name is Cara flake and I
have the pleasure of working at the
McGovern Institute for brain research
here in this building we are especially
pleased to welcome folks from the class
of 59 today that was Pat McGovern's
class and many of you probably knew Pat
together with laurihart McGovern his
wife who's right here they they founded
the McGovern Institute for brain
research in the year 2000 we now have 19
faculty members and more than 300
scientists and engineers from many
departments across MIT all devoted to
understanding the brain McGovern
research ranges from studying molecular
genetics that play a role in brain
disorders to understanding the neural
circuits that underlie learning and
behavior all the way through to studying
the complexities and nuances of the
whole human mind we also engineer
breakthrough technologies that are used
by thousands of scientists and
clinicians all around the globe I'm very
pleased today to introduce our director
Bob DeSimone Bob joined MIT in 2004 in
his in addition to being director of the
McGovern Institute he is also the Doris
and Don Berkey
professor of neuroscience in the
department of brain and cognitive
sciences
prior to joining MIT bob was director of
the intramural research program at the
National Institute of Mental Health his
own lab here at McGovern studies the
mechanisms of attention today bob is
pleased to share with you some of the
strides being made at McGovern to
understand and develop new solutions for
complex brain disorders please help me
welcome Bob DeSimone
[Applause]
well welcome it is great to have you
here this is a really special couple
days I I'm going to talk about what we
know about brain disorders I'm going to
use some of the work from the McGovern
Institute to highlight these stories but
you know this regard this like an MIT
classroom you know it's better if you
interrupt if it could be a little little
interactive no really you you want it
all like digested and fed to you it's
just passive recipients okay all right
that's what it was like when you were
here not anymore
all right well the and we're gonna we're
gonna we had reserved these first couple
rows for class of 59 but but wait but
they're not all full so feel free if
you're in the back to take a class of 59
honorary seat so as Karen mentioned the
McGovern Institute was founded by Patton
Lori McGovern and we have Laurie
McGovern here with us today
in fact Laurie is it
or is it many of our events and I think
I think are you an honorary class of 59
member I think they've accepted you into
the fold very good and when it was
founded it had a dual mission which was
to first understand the brain this is
our basic research mission is always the
foundation of what we do here and then
the but the second part was to take what
we've learned about the brain and to try
to apply that to help people suffering
from any form of brain disorders and
also we try to help in education and
development of technology and some of
those are different stories the approach
that we take here is a multi-level
approach so we go from genes to cells to
circuits to cognitive function and even
computational neuroscience and our
faculty members who are shown here
span this whole range and you'll notice
that many of them actually are sitting
at the intersection of these different
levels because their work bridges across
the different levels and we have a very
distinguished faculty we have the ones
highlighted in blue are members of the
National Academy of Science we have won
Nobel Prize winner Bob Horvitz and I'd
say it's really been a privilege for me
to work with them since I've come here
to MIT and on the problem that we are
turning our attention to is just a
really really serious problem in health
which is all the various forms of brain
disorders which affect people and they
felt coursing not to only affect that
the person with the disorder but their
whole family you know it's it's
everyone's everyone's drawn in and I
would like to be able to tell you that
of course we've been making steady
progress and there's fewer and fewer
people diagnosed with brain disorders
every year but it's the exact opposite
right there's actually more and more
people diagnosed with various forms of
brain disorders every year
and into a certain extent it's just
better assessment we're getting better
and better at recognizing things that
affect people's brain and affects their
behavior and also I think we are making
some progress in reducing the stigma of
brain disorders so people are more
willing to admit it so they come to our
attention and but then once they come to
our attention it's just staggering how
many people have some problem affecting
their brain course you know we think all
of our behaviors coming from our brain
so it's not as though you know we have
other the other behavior that's not
affected by our brain right everything's
affected by our brain and we can
identify various ways in which it may
not be working optimally if you look at
the impact of brain disorders just sewn
here in this graph for the - for both
neurological disorders and in mental
disorders as a proportion of all the
different impacts on what they called
disability adjusted life years which are
all the days of disability that are
affected by and you name it and the
thing about many of the forms of brain
disorders is they start when you're
young and they impact you for your
entire life you may be dealing with some
of these problems for 50 years and
whereas in some other diseases
unfortunately people may die quickly but
it means that they're not they're not
suffering from a disability for 50 years
and you know it may be far less so that
the disability impact is is huge and you
know you just pick up the newspaper
these days or actually I guess and pick
up your Kindle these days and and read
you know what's happening in the health
field medicine medical field and of
course there's all the dramatic
improvements that are being made in many
areas of health and you know we of
course I mean all know that you know
first the most famous examples is in
suppo leo base you know almost wiped out
you look at the incidence of HIV more
modern problem deaths from HIV Dramat
quickly falling you look at deaths from
cancer another you know it's not as
dramatic as what there's some of the
changes we've seen in HIV for example
but there's steady reductions in deaths
from cancer deaths per 100,000
population and this actually this graph
starts stops early but this decline has
continued and is projected to continue
off into the next few years and so you
could ask so what's responsible for all
these improvements that are being made
in other areas of healthcare well it's
really it's they're based largely on a
better mechanistic understanding of
disease and you know just get you know
just one of many examples is the my
logic
chronic myelogenous leukemia which was
identified actually many years ago as
being associated with a genetic mutation
in a tumor and having identified the
genetic mutation physician scientists
were able to identify an altered gene
product and then having that gene
product they were able to develop a drug
Gleevec one of the great success stories
of modern medicine
that could block the action that was
causing the cancer and it's essentially
eliminated this disease and and so it is
especially frustrating that we're not
seeing the same kind of progress in
brain disorders and yes well why so why
is it everybody else gets that the
benefits of everything we're doing in
medical research and why aren't we
getting it in in brain disorders and the
answer is we do not have that
mechanistic understanding if we have do
not have the identified gene product the
target for the drug they ask if I asked
anybody now you know what's the what's
the mechanistic cause of schizophrenia
you don't know what's the mechanistic
cause a depression you don't know people
think that we know because we have some
drugs that work through certain
neurotransmitter systems but there's
absolutely no reason to believe that
those drugs work because the problem is
in that neurotransmitter system right
aspirin works for me you know when
aspirin reduces your fever it says not
getting at the cause of the fever is
reducing a symptom of the fever and
that's the problem that we have in brain
disorders and that just means we're
further behind in some air other areas
of medicine and and we have a more
difficult problem right it's a lot
easier to understand what's say going on
with your liver or your kidney than it
is with your brain and you know when a
patient goes to their doctor and they
have a kidney problem it can be examined
and if you have a tumor you can take
pieces of it out but it's not very often
you're going to go into your doctor and
he's going to take out a piece of your
brain and examine it right and so it's a
much more difficult problem and so we're
further behind and so we need to need to
gain that mechanistic understanding and
if you look at you know what's the
what's the road map how do how do we get
there okay and the road map really comes
from all the other areas of Medicine you
identify genetic vulnerabilities you use
all the new tools that are being
developed to try to understand how you
can go from a genetic vulnerability to
an altered emotion or brain cells that
are dying or whatever we dealt we have a
better understanding of how those
genetic vulnerabilities link the changes
in our brain circuits and we develop
animal models for testing developing and
testing new treatments we use tools like
brain imaging in people which is our
non-invasive way of looking at brain
activity and then with all that in hand
we can then begin to develop new
treatments and so the roadmap is clear
but we'll talk a little bit about what's
the reason for hoping that we are going
to make progress following that that map
well I told you so that you know the
starting point for a lot of this work
today is our understanding of the
genetic vulnerabilities that lead to a
lot of these brain disorders and the
work that's going on at genetics is
totally revolutionized this field in
just the last few years a lot of of the
work is being led by the Broad Institute
across the street and our close
collaborators of ours and they're doing
what we what we've learned about
genetics and disease is that we used to
think that you shouldn't you could be
able to do genetics on a couple of dozen
people find some big mutation and then
you know you know end a story you know
you've got your answer but it turns out
that the genetic effects from any
individual genes are usually small and
so we need many thousands of people in
these samples we did not understand that
just a few years ago so there's the rush
around the world to collect these very
large samples of people a hundred
thousand people is not too many in these
some of these genetic studies and
they're paying off they are identifying
genes that contribute to these
vulnerabilities these are just some of
the confirmed psychiatric risk variants
up to actually up until a few years ago
it's going way beyond that now
we now have identified hundreds of
genetic vulnerabilities and one of the
really surprising things that's come out
of this is that many genes that lead to
vulnerabilities in one form of brain
disorders is leading to vulnerabilities
and other brain disorders as well and so
you might see you know in a family you
might see depression but you might also
see autism or you might see
schizophrenia pop up across the
generations and we're beginning to
understand that some of these things are
have shared vulnerabilities that we need
to understand
and these are just some of the again
this is from a few years ago but numbers
of genes that have been identified that
event that are associated with in this
case psychiatric disorders okay so what
are some of the new tools we have
available for understanding the impact
of these genetic vulnerabilities on
neural circuits and brain function now
I'm going to give you a couple examples
from the work of Edie Boyden and Fung
Jung two of our faculty members here
Edie
one that I putting up as an example from
expansion microscopy because this is one
of his latest discoveries Edie has
discovered a way to essentially blow up
brain tissue so that things that were
formerly very difficult to visualize
with microscopes now become visible even
with conventional microscopes and what
you saw there which you saw a piece of
an expanding brain tissue he's figured
out a way of using some of the materials
that go into baby diapers your writing
you know I have a baby diaper you know
the fundamental principle of a baby
diaper is you put a little bit of liquid
on it and blows up right so he figured
it if you put some of the same material
into into brain it will allow the brain
to blow up when you put it in saline and
he does it in a way where all the micro
structure is preserved I mean down to
the nanometer the structure is preserved
and I'm just going to show you as an
example
this is these this is this is thing this
is a neural circuit and with some of the
little little dots you see in this
circuit are the synapses between the
individual cells which were now able to
visualize and really unprecedented
detail I think what this this slide was
mean I think ed was up to five times
linear expansion I think he's now up to
20 times linear expansion it's really
it's growing dramatically and and and
not only are we able to visualize the
structure but we're now able to tag
these with genes that are active for
example and we're gonna and we're able
to do this in both in normal control
populations disease populations and so
on this is totally revolutionising our
ability to localize where some of these
changes are affecting function and brain
another really revolutionary method that
Edie co-developed is what's known as
optogenetics now in optogenetics you
insert a some genetic material into
neurons and so this is why it's been
done mostly an animal so far and that
but then having inserted that genetic
material neurons become sensitive to
light okay I'll show you that video
again oops what's that there was algae
though so is using material from the
natural world I that gave algie's light
sensitivity and Edie
and his collaborator Karl dust Dicer off
and Fung John when he was a graduate
student at Stanford decided they would
test this in neurons and discovered that
it worked in neurons and now using light
usually laser light you can now activate
individual cells or different PUD cells
and populations and circuits and for the
first time really test the function of
some of these neurons in these circuits
and understand what's going wrong and
genetically defined subtypes of neurons
and and it's Duras now there's a lot of
interest in using this clinically of
course the the hesitation is for brain
you we don't want to jacked a lot of
genetic material into brain so it's
we're currently it's mostly being used
an eye disease as there's already
clinical trials on your way to restore
blindness and people by making some of
the non receptor elements in your eye
sensitive to light and now as you could
bypass for example
photoreceptors like you haven't
retinitis pigmentosa and this is under
clinical development there's some other
peripheral applications but well I think
what we'll see over the next five years
or some applications in in brain as well
but because these are it's an invasive
method that has also been interested in
developing non-invasive methods that can
be used in people for stimulating brain
activity and not just as a way of as a
research tool to understand how the
brain is working but as a therapy and
many of you know about deep brain
stimulation being used in Parkinson's
disease for example where you have an
electrode been planted and you have and
it can completely turn off the tremor
that you see in someone with Parkinson's
and there's increasing interest in using
the stimulation approach to push the
brain in different directions that will
be beneficial in a variety of forms of
brain disorders so what Edie
started to do was to use electrical
stimulation from outside the skull but
you're the one you do when P other
people have done OUP's electrical
stimulation from outside the skull
the problem is OUP's has been that it's
not very focused right it just you put a
pad and he put electricity and it's
going to go all over the place and so
what he's been developing years ways of
focusing this stimulation using
different frequencies from different
electrodes and then by by calculating
where the interference patterns should
be at different p frequencies he can
tune where the stimulation is affecting
the brain so for the first time we have
a way of targeting with external
stimulation start targeting individual
parts of the brain which can now be
stimulated and this is an active
development as well and this is just you
this is now an MRI image of people that
have had this this stimulation applied
and these colored spots or the areas
where the stimulation activated brain
activity you can see how it's it's much
more focused
than just this the few state that we
used to have before and I think this is
something that will also have direct
clinical applications now going way over
to the molecular scale I think probably
I think everybody these days has heard
about CRISPR and CRISPR methods for
doing genome editing basically the
ability to edit the genome the way you
would you know edit text with the word
processor that was developed in cells by
Fung Jung here and the in fact just
today I don't know how many of you saw
the news reports just today a new paper
came out by Fung reported him was either
science or nature whose science
reporting a completely new way of doing
this genome editing but in non-dividing
cells that the the original method that
was developed required dividing cells
which would be useful in developing
animals or possibly developing people we
won't go there right now
but but but your brain is full of nine
dividing cells right so it's no longer
dividing and so it's been a real
challenge of how you might use CRISPR oh
and brain but now fungus has developed a
new way based on jumping genes for
inserting new brain mature good question
so well you know our brain is plastic
because you did get an education here at
MIT right and I guarantee you it was
changing your brain and so that kind of
plasticity
that's natural we're all or are born
with that kind of plasticity the
question now people have been asking is
how can we use some of these plastic
mechanisms of the brain and hijack them
for other purposes to get them to solve
some of the problems the brain has using
all new ways so for example in my own
lab one of the things that
we're trying to do is to change how
people pay attention and change their
ability to pay attention using
neurofeedback based on using us what's
known as magneto encephalography picking
up brain signals a very high resolution
and giving them that feedback and the
ability to control their own attentional
state so we're hijacking the brains of
natural plastic mechanisms but by giving
people a different kind of information
about their own brains which they never
had before you and I could ever gain
insight into what's happening in your
own brain but by giving that as feedback
actually enabling people to use these
plastic mechanisms maybe to overcome a
problem so it is we are trying to make
use of the brains neuroplasticity for
solving some of these problems that's
right
well biochemistry is extremely important
because again we're trying to understand
the actions of genes
Gene's work through other molecules
inside of cells those are mostly
biochemical pathways that are being
influenced by these genes and not only
is it giving us some insight into how
different mutations affect these
pathways differently but if you're going
to develop a drug therapy that's it
we'll get to that in a moment
you're gonna develop a drug therapy
you're generally looking at ways of
getting molecules in influencing these
pathways and so on what methods like
CRISPR are doing or at least raising the
possibility that in the future there
will be non drug therapies there will be
there will be biological but not using
drugs in the way they nearly normally
think of them will be going in there and
manipulating the genes directly and some
of you who may have recently seen some
of the some of the new approaches in
spinal muscular atrophy is a new gene
therapy of
that was just approved and there may be
many more of these things but right now
they're extremely therefore they're not
very many they're incredibly expensive
but this is the very this is the very
beginning days right this is all going
to change in the next few years well
I'll get to that in just a moment but
Chris Berg gives us a research tool and
potentially a therapy and and one of the
reasons that this becomes so important
in thinking about say treating it
disorder like like autism is we now
understand that disorders like autism
they may have a common name but they
don't necessarily have a common basis
and so there could be different genetic
forms of autism and if you're going to
go in and try to help someone with one
genetic mutation it necessarily isn't
going to help somebody with a different
genetic mutation and so it's going to
lead us really into the year of
precision medicine for brain disorders
where it's not it's not a you know 1:1
medicine treats all it's going to be
identifying what's wrong in that
individual patient and targeting what's
wrong in them and and autism is
certainly an instance of that and one of
the things that Fung has been developing
that could be used in brain potentially
now and it's under active development is
instead of targeting DNA which has been
lends itself more easily to dividing
cells he's targeting RNA which is a
product of genes and RNA you can target
without without cells having to be
dividing can be done in adult cells and
I think that's where most of the action
is going to be and all these brain
disorders we're not we're not going
after embryos were going after adults
adults or children that are born I have
a problem but we're still going to be
able to go in and manipulate gene
products to help them in RNA editing is
is a possible way of of doing gene
therapy and adults
another it's really to me very
surprising application of CRISPR methods
is actually in diagnosis and detection
and fungus developed the way a new
method called Sherlock some of you may
have heard about for detecting
incredibly small amounts of genetic
material with very simple methods almost
like the pregnancy test very small
amount of some could be saliva could be
blood could be urine in which you detect
tiny amounts of genetic material very
simple devices and so it's being used
right now for example for detecting Zika
virus in populations where in a lot of
places where Zika is developing they
don't have access to very sophisticated
genetic sequencing machines and so on
very expensive sophisticated labs and so
on and but with using these CRISPR base
methods they have got a very inexpensive
testing devices and and very very rapid
detection of very tiny amounts of
infectious material and now it's also
being applied to detect detecting
genetic mutations in people initially
it's going to be in cancer if you have
some very simple test will identify
whether you have a mutation associated
with different types of cancer and then
we're expecting this to be used in brain
disorders in the future as well so
simple testing into the precision
medicine identifying what's wrong in
each individual person and then
targeting what's wrong in their
treatment for in that person so now I've
been telling you a lot about what's
going on at the gene level but of course
genes themselves don't do anything
except by influencing the neural
circuitry in our brain right that's how
we get behavior that's how we get
thinking that's how we get thought it's
all based on neural circuits and one of
our the people that is one of the world
leaders in understanding the function of
neural circuits is Ann Graybiel right
here in our Institute who has been
studying neural circuitry in animal
models and I can give you
any examples from ants lab but I just
wanna pick I picked this one of the more
recent ones where she study the neural
circuitry involved in the kind of
decision that we are making all the time
every day were faced with decisions
where you're balancing risk versus
reward so in this case she was studying
mice who were going for different
amounts of sugar and cups but some of
them were associated with a bright light
which is very aversive to a mouse they
don't like being in bright light and so
they had to weigh well worth you know
that amount of risk of a bright light by
going after what I think is actually the
bigger reward down this alley or should
I take the safe route which is not
associated with bright lights but it's
associated with lesser reward always a
balance and what she's found identified
as a circuitry that seems to be
adjusting between those those two
alternatives and by manipulating the
circuits in one way or another she can
nudge the the mouse that take more risk
in one circumstance or nudge the mouse
to be more cautious in another and we
think that yeah the same mouse she can
she can alter the circuit in two
different ways but depending on which
neuron she's targeting and get it to do
one versus the other
and this is really a lot of this
decision-making that we face is really
the essence of a lot of our anxiety
right you take the riskier alternative
more anxious it turns out that some of
these circuitry's are sort of naturally
biased towards this generation of
anxiety you know you do make they make
even normal decisions seeing risky and
it generates a lot of anxiety and so
it's like the circuitry needs to be sort
of shifted back into a less risky
analysis of that situation
well mice she can do it with
optogenetics so just like that method I
told you with the shining the light so
she can insert these a tiny fiber optics
with the laser targeting genetically
identified cells and then by targeting
with with one color of light or with one
fiber she can influence one group of
cells and then with another fiber or a
different genetic targeting another
group of cells that's really a marker
it's like playing the piano but with
neural circuits another another approach
that ends taking in collaboration with
one of our other scientists here at MIT
Bob Langer ISM many of you've heard of
Bob Langer and as I'm working with Bob
Langer for developing these micro probes
for both monitoring neural activity and
injecting tiny amounts of drugs in a
specific circuit and I think this is
going to be another approach in the
future right now you go to your doctor
he gives you a medicine you take a pill
it's affecting your whole body right and
that's why it's so so you get a medicine
and then you may have to take six other
medicines to control the side effects of
some of the other medicine is you're
always that chasing the side effects
because nothing is targeted it's just
all these off-target effects so when an
is trying to do is develop these probes
with Bob with this collaboration with
Bob Langer that would target the
specific circuit so she identifies the
circuits in her studies in mice and then
the idea would be if you understand the
circuit problem developed this kind of
implantable probe that could develop
deliver the medicine
to just the one place where it needs to
be applied and not bathing the whole
body in a chemical that you may have
untoward side effects
now another application of the CRISPR
methods I mentioned animal models that
is in developing better animal models
and particularly primate models is
something that we become very interested
in Wapping Fung is leading this effort
here and we have a paper coming out next
week in nature or reporting the first
findings from developing these genetic
models in primates for a specific form
of autism the it turns out that these
genetic studies that are identifying the
vulnerability genes are discovering that
a lot of the vulnerability genes for
brain disorders are affecting proteins
in the synapse and the synapse is how
the neurons communicate with each other
and it turns out that that communication
channel is where a lot of the problems
are coming from as they're incredibly
complicated it's about just you know the
synapse is one thing up against another
it's not like an electrical just
electrical coupling many many many
complicated proteins interacting in ways
of bringing molecules into a cell get
into nucleus affecting cell machinery
and so on and so there's basically a lot
of things that can go wrong and so a lot
of genes can influence these the
synapses in bad ways and one of the one
of the mutations that's noted to be
associated with form of autism is in a
gene called shank 3 at least to a
disorder a specific subtype of autism
known as Phelan McDermid syndrome and
the single mutation and the shanked 3
gene essentially gives you this disorder
it's like virtually a hundred percent of
the people with this mutation develop
feeling McDermott syndrome and by
inserting this mutation into mice
actually whooping had promising evidence
that they could be affecting mice
behavior in a way that had some
resemblance to humans but one of the
biggest frustrations in this whole field
is we based so
of our neuroscience on mice but when we
develop treatments in mice and we try
them in people they don't work right how
many times you've seen this you now you
pick up the newspaper know this disease
has been cured in a mouse that diseases
been cured of the mouse if you have
Alzheimer's you have autism you you're a
mouse you're in great shape you know a
mouse doctor hay cure you right away
right the problem is in person the
person goes to the doctor and says sorry
you're not a mouse and because they're
not working and it's maybe not I mean so
mice are so radically different from
people so it maybe we shouldn't be so
surprised that things that work in my
cell necessarily work in people and so
one of our I'd say a great hope here
because it s so far we haven't it hasn't
led to a treatment yet but we're right
we're on the cusp is that by using
primate models primates have brains that
are much more similar to human so this
is just showing the you know the human
brain compare you and brain compared to
am this is a large monkey brain and this
is a mouse brain and not only is it just
the difference in brain size but for the
a similar volume we humans and actually
shared with other primates have seven
times the number of neurons right the
circuits have seven times the number of
neurons you can figure it's going to
work a little differently than in a
mouse right and so and and one of the
one of the the parts of the brain that
it's most implicated in a lot of these
psychiatric disorders it's known as the
prefrontal cortex the prefrontal cortex
area shown in blue green and blue here
which is huge in humans is pretty big in
primates and is miniscule in the mouse
brain and so we feel like we have a lot
more of the circuitry to work with in a
primate model and so using the CRISPR
method what Peng has been able to insert
these mutations into monkeys in this
first project is say there's a
collaboration with our colleagues in
China
and and the shank three mutation has
been inserted that was asserted into the
primate embryos and now that and then
those those monkeys grew up and the your
behavior was tested and we saw a lot of
behavioral differences in those primates
that resembled what's seen in Phelan
McDermid syndrome stereo de peas so you
know a big problem in autism people
develop these these carrot you know
motor stereo de Peas they may be
different in different people some with
a hands someone head banging and same
thing in monkeys it turns out they also
develops areata Peas but one monkey
it'll be this thing one monkey will be
that thing they're different like people
it's not just one thing but it's
abnormal what they're doing sleep
disorders very common problem in autism
not just feeling McDermott system of
many forms of autism people complain
that they think I can't sleep and the
same thing is found in the monkeys that
when you look at and you monitor you put
activity monitors on them either will
watch not the Apple watch but like a
monkey in version of the Apple watch or
or a collar with the monitors their
activity you can see that their sleep is
the Sterlite there they get up get up
and they have trouble going to sleep and
they wake up or you know again and again
it's found out the found as well and if
you look at their social behavior you
can see differences as well now this is
a video of two normal monkeys they're in
separate cages before the test and that
technician comes in and he pulls out the
divider so now the two monkeys for the
first time get to experience each other
and you know they're a little wary you
know not going up and hugging each other
right away but they're checking each
other out right it says normal monkey
behavior as they as the monkeys try to
get to know each other
good question I don't know in this video
but we've tried all the different gender
comparisons of male/female feel if you
own someone okay so now we're gonna do
the same test or show you a video of the
same test but this time there's a the
control monkey is is over here and that
animal with the shank three mutation is
over there and did i just mess up on
that see I think I made it okay yeah one
of the things that we say here that was
one thing that I was gonna show you oh
did you see that much see that monkey
flipping over and over again very
abnormal normal monkeys do that very
rarely that's one of the stereotype ease
that this monkey developed is flipping
so now the experimenter comes in he
pulls out the divider and you could see
this nut doesn't have that same kind of
interest in the other monkey he's I mean
he's nearby but he's just looking off
looking off away as does it seems not
interested in that social exploration
which has some again reminiscent of some
aspects of some of the social problems
that we see in in human autism okay and
then when we do MRI in these monkeys we
took we can look at both structural
differences it turns out they have
reduced grey matter but also we can look
at the connectivity in the brain using
an MRI and what we find is just a
different pattern of connectivity in
these monkeys in some areas we see
increased connectivity and local
circuits and some areas we see reduced
activity reduce connectivity but the
area is where we see the increased
connectivity tend to be sensory areas
and it's interesting you know one of the
one of the things that people on the
autism spectrum complain about a lot
is increased sensory sensitivity very
very sensitive to lights and sound and
so on they really bother them and what
we're seeing is what could be a neural
basis for this in the brains of these
monkeys and so you know this is the kind
of thing we need we need biomarkers we
need areas to target and we need things
that can we can go in and if we test the
treatment we need to be able to go back
in and look at the MRI and see how it's
changing the connectivity for example
this is all that all that monkey work
has done is a collaboration in China but
we have here at MIT we're not able to do
work with those big monkeys and these
genetic studies are just not even the
space for it but we've developed a
another primate as a marmoset these are
tiny little primates really the size of
rats and so it's possible they live in
goo cages and you know many more of them
more fun than a barrel of monkeys here I
can tell you we have our first marmoset
colony here at MIT and we're doing the
first genetic manipulations and so we'll
be having a parallel program here at MIT
to the one that we have it within our
collaboration in China so let me go back
to the human brain imaging and talk
about how we use brain imaging to try to
understand what's going on in informs of
brain disorders I want to take Li focus
on the work of Nancy kanwisher Rebecca
Saxe and John Gabriele III of our
faculty members here Nancy kanwisher is
the world leader in identifying the
functions of different parts of the
cortex what she's shown is a functional
localization for many different aspects
of the processing of the sensory world
we have parts of the brain that are
specialized for the perception of faces
shapes language seeing the bodies of
other people and so on these are all all
these different colored regions here are
the areas that Nancy is identified with
these sort of functional specializations
and one since one of the some one of the
areas with this functional
specializations are involved
and face perception so that is a
possibility you think that you know
sometimes people with with autism for
example complain or seen that they don't
pay attention to faces or afraid of
looking at faces don't look at the eyes
of faces and so on and and Rebecca Saxe
is taking this even further and looking
at the functional localization of really
advanced cognitive functions including
what she calls theory of mind in other
words how do we how do we understand
what someone else is thinking right we
do this all the time or think well what
are they thinking right it turns out we
have func specialized circuits for that
kind of thinking and again it was the
kind of thing that you would hope that
you might be able to get some insight
and to say a disorder like autism by
understanding what's going on in there
in these thinking about other people's
minds areas and I have to say that it's
turning out to be very very challenging
so far because a lot of these studies
have not been targeted to the different
genetic forms of autism so a lot of this
work we've been doing in just general
autism populations and and there's so
much variability in it that it's been
very difficult to identify problems that
are common across the whole say autistic
spectrum population but Nancy and
colleague Caroline Roberts have
identified a perceptual problem and in
people on the autism spectrum that seems
like it could turn into a biomarker what
she says is she has people looking at
different patterns with the two
different eyes and normally if you see
two different patterns with your two
eyes you switch back and forth you can
exceed them both at the same time you
switch back and forth between them and
the rate at which people on the autism
spectrum switch back and forth is much
reduced compared to the normal controls
and this is people doing work in animals
as I have identified this problem as
associated with an imbalance in the
excitatory and inhibitory transmitters
in the cortex and that's a common source
of speculate
about what's one of the problems in
autism and Nancy is now actively
pursuing this as a biomarker and adding
Carolina in in autistic populations John
Geary le has been applying his brain
imaging approach to understanding a
variety of disorders including dyslexia
in children and comparing dyslexic
children with normal normally reading
children he's identified brain circuits
that appear to be different between the
two groups involving many areas involved
in language and and perceptual
processing and so on and now having
identified these and in kids who are
already reading John's now be able to go
back in and look at the connectivity of
these areas in kids before they read and
so the goal is to try to identify kids
who are going to later develop dyslexia
and then target those for an
intervention so that they get off to in
the reading to a much stronger start and
those are studies underway and a related
project we have and I have to take this
one because one of my my favorite
projects that I've been involved with
and another collaboration with China
we've been trying to see if early music
education and particularly in this case
piano education and kindergarten
children leave to generalize brain
improvements in kids and you know many I
don't know how many of you have children
or if you whether you studying music or
your kids have study music you all know
kids so you know study music is cuz it
aren't incredibly talented actually the
when I came here I was one of the things
I was surprised that was hearing that
MIT students they may be engineering
majors or science majors but many of
them have musical backgrounds and
continue to take music instruction at
MIT many of you had musicians released
as children were you music musicians
yeah very very common here at MIT
and so the question is was that a cause
or an effect right are you attracted to
music because you were a smart kid who
he was able to pay attention to music or
that you early music education make me
smarter and more focused right as if
it's actually a fundamental question
well yeah
could be a [ __ ] or they call it
virtuous cycle but you need a clinical
trial right you need actually but the
only way you get an answer to these
kinds of questions is you actually have
to randomly assign people to the
different groups so in this
collaboration with China we were able to
do that we could randomly assign kids to
either early piano education additional
reading instruction practical issue many
schools have to face do they put their
money into the Arts or they put their
money into more reading and math so in
this case the comparison group was a
reading ger and then another group of
kids who got nothing but at the end of
the study they were offered the free
music lessons so in the end everybody
got something but we studied them before
the control group got them the music
okay and we also took brain measurements
using EEG to see how the brain responded
to hearing different sounds and so on
so it turned out that the kids with the
early piano instruction did the best not
only hearing the differences between
tones but hearing the different switches
between sounds and speech and that's
known to be impaired in kids with
dyslexia or at least of one form of
dyslexia is that there's actually a
speech sound processing problem and kids
actually are not hearing the distinction
between words and that's causing later
reading problems and so that the Pieta
kids with piano instruction were
actually better at understanding words
than the kids who had the extra reading
instruct
it was really quite remarkable and if
you and you look at these brain signals
their brains were picking up these
differences better than the other groups
as well so now the next faith and phase
of the experiment we're going to be
seeing is it the case can we find the
kids who the brains think they'll
suggest or not picking up these sound
differences as well and with the early
music education give them an advantage
to overcome some of these some of these
problems yeah so in some forms of
dyslexia you can give hearing tests that
predict whether the kids going to have a
reading problem that's right now it's
not but the one of the reasons is
controversial again just dyslexia is a
heterogeneous condition as well and
there's only subgroups of kids that have
that problem they don't all have that
problem so you notice we're trying to
understand like you know what's what's
different about one subgroup compared to
another so I just want to give you just
a just a we're coming near approaching
the end about another example of how we
can use social anxiety I'm sorry use
brain imaging to understand a disorder
that would lead to better treatment as
John's been looking at social anxiety
disorder and looking at the differences
in brain activation between people that
respond well to treatment compared to
people who don't this is a this is
behavioral therapy for anxiety disorder
some people respond really well so some
people don't and it turns out you can
identify these two groups from there the
responses to different perceptual images
and now John's trying to use that to
make predictions about who will respond
best to treatment so
so in children he's identified kids who
are what we call at risk for depression
compared to a normal control group and
the kids who were defined as at greater
risk for depression or ones that have
for example a parent who suffers from
depression so they're at higher risk and
he compares them to the kids with them
that don't have this high risk in their
background and he looks at their brain
response while they're looking at images
of other people's faces expressing
different emotions and it turns out that
in the high-risk kids they're showing a
decrease response in some of these brain
circuits when they look at happy faces
and an increased response when they're
looking at fearful faces as though
they're actually more sensitive to the
negative emotions in other people than
the positive emotions now these are kids
who are showing current they're not
depressed these are normal kids
at higher risk but they seem to be
processing the sensory input differently
than the control group and so but he
used so then he uses just the brain
imaging pattern to predict who will
develop depression or anxiety disorders
three or four years later and he's he's
comparing the predictions from the F the
fMRI data which is the yellow bars
compared to using behavioral symptoms
for predicting whether they're going to
suffer from these these disorders and it
turns out they're more accurate and
they're more sensitive the brain imaging
predictions then even the behaviors that
are related to that you're seeing and
depression so again it's it's at least
promising that we might be able to
identify kids early who are at risk of
developing depression and develop a
better intervention
we're meaning to to we're going to run
out of time so I'm going to skip ahead
and say so where's what's the what's
what's the roadmap look like over the
next five years you know what can you
expect from these kinds of brain
research studies so I think it's based
on everything that we've seen over the
next five years we're going to have a
better genetic understanding of all
these kinds of disorders I've talked
about we'll have much better
understanding of the different subgroups
that end up with the same label we're
going to have better animal models that
are going to lead to we're gonna happen
it's gonna lead to a better
understanding that will lead to new
treatments and it will give us a way of
testing those treatments in a way that
we hope will be more predictive of how
they'll how they'll work when we apply
them in human beings will identify the
affected cells in circuits will have new
targets for drug development I think we
will see the first applications of gene
therapy in brain disorders over the next
five years and I believe we're gonna
have better brain base predictors of
who's going to have problems either in
education or suffering from different
forms of depression anxiety and so on
and kids and that's gonna lead to better
interventions so that's where I think
we're going these are the again this is
the roadmap I think that's been
successful in other areas of Medicine
it's going to be successful in brain
disorders and I think we're just going
to have to be patient for a few more
years yeah
so a good point so you put your finger
on a key problem but I want to
distinguish penetrance from heritability
so the penetrance issue is that for a
lot of these disorders we've identified
many genes any one of which has a very
small impact so you might have a
mutation but the probability you're
going to end up with disorder is very
small that's low penetrance okay but the
disease can be highly heritable because
it's a lot of genes acting together so
the heritability of all these disorders
is very high so you know if you're
looking at the transmission through
parents to the kids you know their hair
you can compare identical twins to
fraternal twins heritability is up
around 80% most of these disorders so
you know there's a very strong genetic
basis but it may involve a lot of genes
and that is a key problem so you have
two two ways of thinking about that one
is that we go after the highly penetrant
genes which are being identified that
when we understand how they work we
white as a mutation in this one gene
lead to a high probability of a
particular disorder that we will
identify the circuits that are being
influenced by lots of other genes as
well and then once you identify that
circuit now you have a target for
therapy and it's going to help everybody
even with the apologetic forms of
disorder so that's one and the other
possibility is we may need to model the
impact of lots of these different genes
so we're gonna be much more challenging
but some of the new bait CRISPR based
methods allow us to target many genes at
the same time and so we will be
targeting you know the highest impact
genes and see you know what's how many
do you need to affect and is there a
common circuitry that they're all
affecting right so it's challenging but
I think you know we have a reasonable
path for how to study in the future
let's go to the back
yeah great questions you know it's James
our environment so you know sometimes
genes work through behavior so in other
words you could have a genetic
predisposition for creating an
environment that leads to your children
being depressed in fact it's actually
there's a lot of a lot of support for
that idea that that one of the biggest
impacts a parent has on their child is
what environment they raise them in and
so I mean some ways you know we've is
really a difficult to tease those apart
but they're all working through the
brain eventually right so if the kids
the press whether it's just you know
they got to press strictly through a
genetic cause release or they got
depressed
because of the environmental influences
it's affecting we believe some of these
circuits in the similar way and so we're
hoping that we can target depression
using therapies that don't that don't
distinguish between whether you had a
genetic cause or an environmental cause
but maybe in the end we'll we'll have to
treat kids differently depending on
genetic basis lots of questions here
let's just take the ones we'll work our
way from the back to the front press it
for a change
so the question was why is it that the
prevalence of some of these brain
disorders is increasing over time
because our genes aren't changing so
much over time right so we have a 20%
increase in increase in childhood
depression our genes are can't be the
cause of that and so I did mention this
at the beginning is that we think we did
we have better assessments of people now
so it's not that it's not the case that
20% more people are truly depressing
than used to be but we're identifying
people with depression better now
likewise with autism likewise what's
concerning all these disorders are being
identified more and and there's as we
reduce the stigma associated with
different disorders people are more
willing to come forward more willing to
talk to their physicians about it and so
on and so now they're there they're now
coming up in the statistics and what
it's telling us is the problem was
bigger than we thought not necessarily
that it's getting worse than we thought
at that time a quarter of a million
people getting polio every year we're
now down that eight in the world
Pakistan and Afghanistan and they hope
to get rid of it in the next few years
if you're retiring all right there you
go yeah
yeah so you asked about Alzheimer's yeah
I was afraid somebody was going to ask
about Valentine yeah they insured you
asked about a particular toxin produced
by plants and whether that might be
might be playing a role you know many of
us were really really really hoping the
amyloid hypothesis of Alzheimer's
disease would turn out to be right
and we just had the worst worse news
with the failed Biogen trial and there
are many people who are willing or ready
to throw in the towel on amyloid and say
it's something else and so unfortunately
it's like we're back to the drawing
board and it's not really clear so
environmental type Al's Alzheimer's
actually as a fairly weak genetic
component so so it's you know it's some
people call it you know it's just this
is a form of aging right that some
people say that yes it could be the
toxins in the current environment that
we didn't used to experience before and
so on
it's really terrible that we're at this
point so far into studying the disease
that we haven't even figured out the
cause yet and so what you're saying it
could be a plant-based toxin I don't
think anything is off the table
so the glial cells are are still very
high up there in terms of people
thinking about you know what's involved
in the disorder but what activates them
or what causes them to work in an
abnormal way I think it still remains to
be understood yeah
about describe the end Greenville study
in Scientific American about creating a
addiction which becomes ingrained and
then she reversed it yeah so this
there's this idea that that addictions
result from a hijacking of our normal
circuits for a reward that you know we
have you could say you know we become
addicted to eating and drinking and
things right we we have our brains are
wired up to strength and behavior that
leads to rewards right and diminished
behavior that doesn't lead to rewards
and that some of the problem is with
some of the addictive substances they
act directly on those same circuits and
so it's like your circuit is now
thinking that you know you're taking
these drugs and that's leading to all
these rewards when actually it's the
exact opposite because there's you've
hijacked them and and so I think it's
you know that's a very active area of
people trying to figure out how to
unhide jack them or how to keep them
from how how to protect these circuits
from being influenced in this way
by drugs of abuse and so on that's as
you know vaccines people talked about
vaccines against addictive drugs I think
it's an area where I have to say we're
where the progress in our understanding
of the disorders are really gaining
quickly and so I'm becoming more
optimistic that they're going to be real
treatments that that come out of it
yeah I read that same news report they
think that you did that Pfizer had an
anti-inflammatory drug a drug that was
using another purpose and and they just
an incidental finding in the study was
that it seemed as though fewer people
had developed Alzheimer's than the
people not taking the drug I also write
I mean so to be you know to give them
the benefit of the doubt they had
determined that the drug actually
Dunstan get into the brain that's not a
good sign
and there are other there are other
anti-inflammatories that don't seem to
be protective against Alzheimer's so I
have to say you know the problem is
these drug companies is they've lost
billions and billions of dollars
pursuing outsiders therapies and and
they're becoming a bit gun shy in fact
that's one of the reasons we're so
focused on developing the better primate
models is just to convince the drug
companies to get back in the game
because they keep I mean they they're
you know realistically saying look we've
been following the mouse work it's not
working and so you know we're saying so
we're getting out of this field you're
laying off there neuroscientists are
getting out of the business and so what
we want to do is we want to have you
know if we if we show that a treatment
works in a preemie that's going to get
their attention again I say well that
now maybe it's worth reinvesting the
money this is going to take to do
another trial but that's where we need
to get we need to get the drug we
absolutely depend on the drug companies
we got to get them back in the game yeah
so I couldn't I'm having our community
Oh periodontal disease yeah yeah I know
I read that too I was really excited
about the possible I'm flossing more
I'm definitely flossing more yeah so I
know I interesting research showing that
you know this relationship between
periodontal disease and Alzheimer's and
they developed a small small molecule
that target that that bacteria better
than the broad-spectrum antibiotics and
they seem to you know have a positive
impact I know that those are going into
clinical trials from some of those
companies right now
well so did the thing is I think you
know it's another example where I think
higher along a lot of other people got
really excited but the problem of you
been our hopes have been dashed so many
times that right but I know but the
trials are going to happen and we will
see absolutely yeah so the question was
that we have we're subjected to so many
toxins many more toxins these days than
people that were in the past and is it
possible that our blood-brain barrier
which is way our brain protects us from
all these toxins in the blood that it's
under more assault these days that's a
very active area that people are working
in there's some Parkinson's disease is
an example where you know the most
prevalent ideas of a lot of Parkinson's
is due to toxins which toxins is another
story quite that isn't quite figured out
but but Parkinson's is an example yeah
all right I said where a lot of this you
know the intake increase in incidence of
disease is better to a bet as dude a
better assessment Parkinson's disease
seems to be a disease that just didn't
exist in the past it's not it wasn't
even as assessment problem it's actually
seems to be a modern disease and and
there that lends itself to these sort of
toxin hypothesis that modern humans are
being exposed to toxins that people in
the past were never exposed to before
and so that yeah I agree that definitely
needs to be is an active area of
research heroin
so your question allows me to mention
that I skipped a turtle is where you
were running out of time - yeah John
Gabriella has been using mindfulness as
an intervention in kids that have been
identified as a trick risk for
developing depression and anxiety and it
seems to be helpful so I I don't know
the details of this but I think that
what what John's doing with in terms of
looking at the brains response when you
look at faces of people carrying
negative emotions and positive emotions
he's seeing how they change with the
mindfulness training so it could be that
that as kids learn to better control
their own emotion their own levels of
anxiety it's changing the brains
response to these you know positive and
negative emotions some people on the
outside so I don't I don't know that I
don't know that specifically but that's
where I think John's going with that
micro dosing of what huh-oh LSD
I don't know that well one more question
yeah
yeah so yeah so and the idea that
there's multiple factors that are all
adding up to you know giving people outs
hymens is certainly a viable idea so you
know when you look at people with
Alzheimer's there's a lot of other
things wrong with them they have may
have a build-up of amyloid in the brain
but I've I've according to research 99%
of people diagnosed with Alzheimer's
have vascular disease and brain and so
you know there's going to be a lot of
factors weighing on the development of
vascular disease so it could be I think
I think we need to